dancing or you may have just heard him
there is it was a senior adviser to the
romney-ryan presidential campaign he was
talking to Republicans last night when
the results came in and speaking to them
again this morning dan good morning good
morning so what message her Republicans
taking away from this split result first
of all they are sort of jostled because
it was not what they expected in other
words if you would if you think back the
last two years of the Trump presidency
so probably one of the most tumultuous
two years in the history of presidential
politics at the beginning of those two
years if this has been a conventional
Republican presidency and you would look
forward to the next two years you would
have said the Republican president would
probably want win the states that that
president want in the Senate that that
president want in the presidential
election the Republicans will probably
lose the house in accordance with
averages about 30 seats it wouldn't be
like you know a dramatic change the diss
the congressional districts that the
Republican opponent had lost would
probably lose exactly what happened
there's been no polarizing radicalizing
moment it's not like Obama 2010 it's not
like Clinton in 94 but you wouldn't say
that way that it was 68 percent approval
for the economy no no absolutely so
there was actually I'm just saying this
has not been like a a siege in in terms
of a radicalized electorate completely
turning Congress upside down that said
that said they are living with the
reality that while it was not a shock to
the system the new reality for House
Republicans and they said that to me
last night they said it to me this
morning is we are about to be besieged
by investigations and the conservative
policy agenda is over you just said it
wasn't really polarizing because I won't
we talked about it last night I woke up
this morning still thinking about it how
President Trump won this election by
putting out tweets and say every time
you see a caravan or people illegally
coming think and blame the Democrats
many gang members and some very bad
people are mixed into the caravan that
just is blatantly not it's polarizing
rhetoric I'm not that's my point my
point is it's it's polarizing rhetoric
you would think the outcome would not be
a split decision
it's basically
that's not true we knew it was going to
be a split decision we knew that those
Senate's are facing tough times in
states that fit he won handily and that
the in the house those house Republicans
that retired and left a lot of open
seats including Speaker Paul Ryan said I
don't want to be around when Democrats
are in charge and he called that all the
way back in January and he feels the
same today is that gonna be the playbook
for the Republicans in 2020 that's
that's I woke up still thinking about
this you know what that this is a
discussion that's happening right now
and it's gonna be happening going
forward because the reality is
Republicans while they did not get as as
shellacked as they thought they might
they lost really important suburban
middle and upper middle class seats and
then it's gonna be hard to build a real
governing majority going forward without
those seats and to your point that's
where women the women vote voters they
lost last night to play a big role in
president right politics right but but I
do think though that the the
investigations is a whole new world and
a lot of Republican you know
conservative minded policy leaders in
the house are not going to be excited
about that environment
all right dance you know are always you
know laying and screaming yelling there
was no yelling damn it it's we're glad
you came all right